hola otra vez bueno vamos a intentar ver
con qué identidad trigonométricas nos
podemos encontrar si iniciamos con
coseno de alfa + beta coseno de alfa +
beta en el vídeo pasado vimos seno de
alfa + beta aquí vamos a ver si podemos
reescribir el coseno de alfa + beta como
una combinación de seno y coseno de alfa
y beta así que vamos a iniciar con esto
sí ya decía viste el vídeo de seno de
alfa más beta la prueba para que usted
no de alfa más beta será muy parecida
muy parecida así que vamos a obtener
algo muy similar y podremos comparar las
diferencias entre las diferencias entre
seno de alfa más beta y coseno de armas
beta a eso ya después al terminar así
que justo como en aquella última prueba
digamos que en este ángulo voy a cambiar
aquí de color
este es el ángulo alfa este es mi ángulo
alfa y digamos que acá tenemos el ángulo
beta este es ángulo beta entonces bueno
queremos ver coseno de alfa + beta donde
alfa + beta es este ángulo grande
y cierto esto es alfa más beta así que
bueno cuál es el cuál es el coste no de
eso soc actúa zocato a coseno es
adyacente sobre hipotenusa choca toa
entonces coseno es es camps sea h
entonces cose no es igual a adyacente
igual a adyacente sobre hipotenusa ahora
bien para este ángulo grande cuál es el
adyacente es la línea hace es cierto así
que esto es igual a la línea al segmento
hace hacer eso es el adyacente la
longitud del segmento hace sobre la
longitud del segmento cuál es cuál es la
hipotenusa ave es cierto ave entonces
hace sobre ave y bueno ya con esto esto
es adyacente sobre hipotenusa veamos qué
podemos hacer ahora bien esto se hace
sobre ave adyacente sobre hipotenusa y
me pregunto si existe otra manera de
escribir hace alguna manera distinta
interesante
algo así para escribirla como
combinación de otras líneas ubicadas en
este en este dibujo entonces veamos que
no es hace lo mismo que hace esta línea
a efe - que es esto estos una de cierto
resonante entonces lo voy a escribir
bien es de dedo entonces a efe - de y
bueno claro subimos que vamos a asumir
que esta línea es perpendicular a esta
otra línea aquí es perpendicular y que
también esta línea es perpendicular a
esta ahí también está es perpendicular
así que estas líneas son perpendiculares
y son perpendiculares porque lo dibujé
de esa forma tal que fueran
perpendiculares pero bueno en fin ahora
ya sabes que esta línea esta es
perpendicular a esta línea es paralela a
esta otra línea de aquí de m y aquí
tenemos la perpendicular y bueno
entonces esta línea a efe esta línea
larga a efe - d
- d eso es igual
y bueno lo voy a escribir acá eso es
igual a efe a efe - d
sobre
todo esto sobre el segmento ab ave y
bueno por supuesto podemos reescribir
esto como lo voy a cambiar de color
primero para más color a ok entonces
podemos escribirlo como a efe sobre ave
y luego cambiar de color verde claro que
menos de d
sobre el segmento ave sobre el segmento
ave así que tenemos lo siguiente tenemos
el segmento a efe sobre avn - el
segmento d es sobre el segmento ave y
son razones que tal vez a primera vista
tú digas bueno no tiene mucho sentido no
sería genial si pudiéramos expresar lo
como a efe sobre a él porque bueno
entonces podríamos decir que estamos
hablando del coste no de alfa y hay que
intentarlo veamos si podemos
reescribirlo como esta primera expresión
así que regresó al color morado para
ubicar a qué expresión me estoy
refiriendo
veamos si puedo reescribir esto como a
efe sobre x alguna cosa podemos hacerlo
algebraica mente esto es equivalente a
tener a efe sobre el segmento
x el segmento hay sobre el segmento ave
y tal vez te preguntes bueno y de dónde
sacas tu beso mi motivación fue tener a
efe sobre a él y simplemente lo acomoda
de tal manera que los a s cancelan a es
sobre a eso es 1 y nos quedaría a efe
sobre ave entonces bueno fue razonable
hacerlo cierto espero lo puedas ver y
ahora cambiar de color al color verde
para hacer algo similar con el otro
término ahora vamos con d es sobre ave
es una razón que tal vez al principio no
tenga mucho sentido pero si yo puedo
hacer de eso breve entonces tal vez si
este ángulo fuera similar a alfa beta
tendría yo algo para avanzar aquí así
que digamos que el segmento pongo menos
de él
d
sobre el segmento b
x bueno sería lo mismo solo tenéis que
multiplicar por b es sobre a b entonces
x b sobre el segmento ave y justo como
en él como en la prueba del seno haremos
lo mismo aquí hay que averiguar cuánto
vale este ángulo de acá arriba porque si
tenemos este dato entonces ya podemos
trabajar con las razones que tenemos acá
así que si este ángulo es alfa entonces
sabemos que este ángulo de aquí también
es alfa porque d en esta línea es
paralela a efe eso lo aprendes en
geometría y si este ángulo de xalpa
sabemos que este ángulo es 90 - alfa
porque son ángulos complementarios así
que todo este ángulo es igualdad a 90 90
entonces esto es 90 menos alfa y 90 -
alfa más 90 más este otro ángulo que no
sabemos cuánto vale la suma de 180
cierto por lo tanto este ángulo también
es igual a alfa y si no me crees puedes
sumar los puede sumar alfa más 90 más 90
menos alfa y obtendrás 180 así que este
ángulo de bm es alfa eso es muy
interesante
y bueno podemos reescribir estas razones
como senos y cosenos de alfaz y betas
así que bueno hay que hacerlo hay que
hacer eso voy a cambiar nuevamente de
color por lo tanto esto esto es igual
que es a efe sobre ay a efe sobre a s
ops y observamos este triángulo
rectángulo es el adyacente sobre la
hipotenusa para alfa cierto
así que adyacente sobre hipotenusa eso
qué es eso es coseno por lo tanto esto
es el coseno de alfa coseno de alfa y
que es sobre ave sobre ave bueno
similarmente si observamos este
triángulo enorme este triángulo grande
que tenemos aquí es el adyacente sobre
la hipotenusa para el ángulo beta así
que esto es el coseno de beta lo escribo
coseno de beta y otra vez cambio aquí de
colores y pongo menos de eso breve
de eso breve esto es alfa cierto este
ángulo es alfa aunque quizás lo escribí
un poco un poquito pequeño pero ese
ángulo es al fallado demostramos sabemos
que eso es alfa d es el opuesto ibex de
hipotenusa y opuesto sobre hipotenusa es
seno por lo tanto aquí tenemos el seno
el seno para el ángulo alfa y ahora que
es b sobre abel b sobre ave nuevamente
nos enfocamos en este triángulo para
beta b es el cateto opuesto a veces la
hipotenusa cateto opuesto sobre pot en
usa para el ángulo beta por lo tanto
aquí tenemos el seno de beta lo pongo
acá abajo porque ya no tengo espacio
entonces aquí es por el seno de beta
bastante genial no crees a mí me parece
muy muy muy padre ahora lo que
aprendimos lo voy a escribir un nuevo
color en un color algo colorido bueno
ay no eso no debía ser o ok lo hago en
azul perfecto ahora
sabemos que sabemos que el coste no de
alfa más beta
eso es igual es igual al coste no de
ambos ángulos eso multiplicado entonces
esto es igual al coseno de alfa coseno
de alfa por el coseno de beta menos el
seno para de ambos también multiplicado
entonces menos el seno menos el seno de
alfa por el seno de beta y está ya quedó
ahí ahora bueno espero te haya gustado
bastante como a mí nos vemos